hier a débuté à Paris la deuxième
session de négociation du traité contre
la pollution plastique le monde s'est
donné pour objectif d'aboutir à un
accord l'année prochaine un accord que
la France au sein de la coalition de
haute ambition emmenée par le Rwanda et
la Norvège souhaite contraignant et
ambitieux avec plusieurs groupes
politiques le groupe démocrate a lancé
un appel en faveur d'un tel traité avec
nos collègues de Renaissance elle est
fit horizon PS écologiste GDR Eliott
nous avons ainsi appelé à soutenir des
objectifs de la coalition qui regroupe
aujourd'hui plus de 50 pays d'abord la
réduction de la production et de la
consommation de plastique ensuite
l'éco-conception des plastiques et enfin
une collecte et un recyclage efficient
monsieur le ministre toute cette semaine
nos pensées accompagneront les
négociateurs français et ceux de nos
partenaires de la collision de la
coalition car Paris devra d'ores et déjà
poser des jalons d'un traité
contraignant et ambitieux
la solution c'est donc la réduction la
réduction encore la réduction par la
suppression des polymères et des
additifs problématiques toxiques et non
recyclables est à la révolution des
usages c'est ça l'esprit des lois avec
et climat la France a ainsi une
législation à l'avant-garde de la lutte
contre la pollution plastique il faut
maintenant assurer sa bonne application
et quand c'est nécessaire prendre des
mesures complémentaires pour garantir
l'atome des objectifs fixés 100% des
plastiques recyclés en 2025 et 0
plastique à usage unique en 2040
l'accompagnement public des entreprises
sera un facteur de réussite de cette
rapide mais indispensable transition
monsieur le ministre comment garantir
l'atteinte de ses objectifs et le
respect des obligations et interdictions
des lois Ajac et climats alors que la
production plastique augmente tous les
jours je vous remercie merci